John Wagner is a business reporter
investing columnist for USA Today and
here with us for the next hour to take
your calls and comments on personal
finance issues what is sort of the
number one question that you're getting
from readers of USA Today they're
concerned about the economy in terms of
how it affects them personally what's
the biggest concern well you know
interesting that the question I've
gotten most is not so much what are the
tax benefits and will my bridge be fixed
but it's more what is the effect of all
this borrowing and all the spending
going to have on inflation and and the
economy as a whole so their concern is
more broadly the government's borrowing
and spending exactly down the road mm-hm
and you know clearly they're concerned
about the economy now and how bad it is
but in the back of their mind they say
well you know gee isn't this ultimately
inflationary and will this how will this
affect me down the road and what can I
do about it based on what you've seen so
far of the stimulus bill to pass late
late Friday right what's in there for
folks individual in terms if they're
interested in buying a house they want
to buy a car is this is going to make it
easier for them to do that oh sure
there's little these things for
everybody really you know the most I
guess the one that most people will feel
the most quickly is the just basically
the tax credit that you get for being a
taxpayer for working and that's a
four-hundred-dollar credit for
individuals and eight hundred dollars
for couples and you know as you know a
deduction is a good thing because it
lowers your taxable income but a credit
is a wonderful thing because it reduces
your tax obligation dollar for dollar if
you have a four-hundred-dollar tax bill
and you get a 400 our tax credit you're
good you got nothing nothing to pay to
the government so that's what people
will feel most immediately but what is
interesting is that it's not going to be
in the form of a rebate check the way
that the previous stimulus was it will
simply for most people they'll see a
bump up in their income it's going to
adjust their withholding so you get as
it were kind of a raise so this will be
a week to week thing you'll see your
yeah yeah that's right so you'll be a
little better off each week rather than
getting
a big chunk of change as you did last
year so that's one thing so first time
home buyers get an eight thousand dollar
up to eight thousand dollar tax credit
which is pretty good and the only catch
there is you can't sell your house again
within three years okay if you do then
you have to give it back so that's to
prevent flipping you know people from
you know just you know walking in which
was an issue had been an issue an
enormous issue I mean that that's
arguably a big reason we're one reason
we're in the trouble we are now you get
you can withdraw excuse me deduct the
sales tax from a car up to forty nine
thousand five hundred dollars worth a
car which is you know a lot of car and a
lot of tax the only caution there is
that it will reduce the amount of state
taxes that you can deduct otherwise so
there's a you know the stimulus it's
designed be broad-based and it's
designed to stimulate spending you know
it's one of these things that you are
rewarded by the government of you if you
spend money well this is a this is there
truly a segment where our viewers and
listeners are really drive what we're
going to talk about here John Wagoner
here for the next fifty five minutes or
so to take your calls on personal
finance the numbers are coming up on
your screen there up on your screen and
we'll go first to Lancaster Pennsylvania
on our Republican line for John Wagner
hi oh good morning mr. Wagner thank you
for being here um i dunno question with
regards to my daughter she purchased us
are you still there lancaster lancaster
pennsylvania twitch astor county
pennsylvania you're on the air go ahead
and yes and she she's had a tough time
she's not for closure but she's
constantly robbing Peter to pay Paul I
couldn't believe it when they gave her
alone in the first place because her
income to my way of thinking would not
allow for her to meet her requirements
with electric and someone so and what my
question is is there a is there a
definite help for somebody who is
constantly robbing Peter to pay Paul
that to keep their head
above water and neither their their
obligations under this program you know
not not so much specifically that what
we'll do is put more money into a pocket
by giving the pay raise we're talking
about it's not a pay raise it's a it's a
it's a tax credit but that will result
in a little extra money in her pocket
what she really needs to do is to go
back to the lenders who have spent some
time on Capitol Hill swearing that
they're going to help these people who
are over their heads and say I need help
you need to you know work with me to
find some way to refigure this loan so
that i can pay it back you can get your
money back and life will be good and
that's really what she needs to do first
and foremost I want to remind all our
viewers and c-span radio listeners to
make sure you turn on your television
when you call in or your radio so you
don't hear yourself feeding back
claysville Pennsylvania is next on are
Democrats line good morning claysville
make sure you turn down your television
or radio there you're going to feed back
on us all right got it thank you go
ahead go ahead with your question yeah
my question is the four hundred dollars
or eight hundred dollars that you get
back you get so much week it comes out
to like thirteen dollars a week that and
the mortgage yeah you gotta 995 dollar a
month payment and 144 dollars a month of
that goes on your principal you call the
mortgage company and they tell you we're
not going to lower your interest rate so
what do you do in a case like that you
know back to the thirteen dollars a week
you can't even take your wife out for
breakfast well you know that is a
problem I mean ultimately they hold the
note and they have spent a whole lot of
time and a whole lot of even they've
even advertised in places saying oh gee
where we're for bearing on all these
poor people that we've sold that we've
you know given loans to I think the next
thing to do is just you know be
persistent keep pushing on it they don't
want to own your house any more than
anybody else they're not in the business
of owning real estate and there are
certainly enough foreclosed homes on the
market the more they put on the market
that just the worse all their other
inventory of foreclosed homes are going
to be you had John John Wagner's our
guests business reporter investment
colonists for a USA Today you also wrote
a book on a bear stearns bail out what
the collapse of bear stearns mean when
you wrote that book did you could you
envision the other collapses and
bailouts that that work that we're
having you wrote this last year right
right after the the build of the
collapse of bear stearns and no i don't
think anybody for saw just how awful
this was going to be that there would be
no major investment banks left and that
you know all these big all these big
banks would fail and that we would be
having the the secretary of the Treasury
and the treasurer and secretary and the
Federal Reserve Chairman saying you know
we're in a mess we have to do something
and you normally when those guys say
things like that I think you have to set
up take notice here bedford indiana next
on our Republican line hi there good
morning and thank you for c-span really
appreciate the possibility to get online
and bring my questions to the special
guests that you have and I'd like to ask
mr. Wagner about a credit card debt I'm
in a position my wife and I on 53 and
we've been married thirty four years and
we've gotten ourselves into credit card
debt last six years wheel about sixty
thousand dollars and we just finished
paying off a house which is worth about
75,000 and of course this is unsecured
debt and and I know that and I'm not too
big to fail I'm too small to save but is
there anything that you could suggest
that I should do to get these credit
cards paid off paid way downs and where
I can
or monthly payments which are just going
now to where they take up all of our
income and then some sure well there's a
couple things first of all any money
that you may be saving at all I don't
know whether you're putting money into
an IRA or 401k right now given the rates
that credit cards charge was anywhere
from 18 to 35 percent which is just very
high if you any dollar you send to them
is the equivalent of earning eighteen to
thirty five percent on your money you're
not going to get that from your mutual
funds I don't think so i think any money
that you're currently saving you should
be directing towards your credit card
you should also start shopping around
and see if you can get a lower rate now
you've paid off your house which is
great but i would argue that you'd be
much better off taking whatever size
home equity loan you can get and paying
off those cards with that the reason for
that is is that your your rate will be
much much lower you'll spread it out
over a longer period of time and the
interest will be tax deductible so
you'll get more of a tax break just for
for owning for having that home equity
line the other thing you should do is
you know be straight with your credit
card people say you know hey I've got a
lot of debt I need to work it down I
want to work it down but you have to to
work with me as well and so those are
your you're really your best avenues but
I think if you can get a home equity
line considering you have a lot of
equity in your home at this point that
would really reduce your payments and
that would that would help you a lot
following up on that caller experiments
there's a article in the business
section of the Philadelphia Enquirer
about a field one field that's growing
is credit counseling right what should
people be aware of when they go to
seeing out a credit counselor right you
should be aware that there are good
credit counselors and bad credit
counselors how do you tell the
difference well what a bad credit
counselor will say is we'll just wipe
out your debt and clean up your give us
X amount of money a thousand dollars
whatever it will give you you know
you'll make your credit rating good as
new and
wipe out your debt and it's not going to
happen it takes a while for your credit
to get cleaned up and there is a
consumer credit counseling organization
that you can find you no legitimate
credit counseling in your area also if
you have a credit union that is
traditionally one of their roles and
they will take a more holistic approach
which is they'll say okay we'll work
with your debts but we'll also see if we
can get you to you know save a little
money so that you're not going to get
into this position again so that you
know you know my personal belief is that
there's little sensor in your bank
account that when you get too much money
your you know your transmission dies so
that basically when you can when you
have one of these emergencies where you
you know have a big bill you won't have
to dip into a credit card you'll be able
to take it from your savings and go from
there and credit unions do a great job
of that and there's plenty of them in
your area probably um have credit unions
fared better than the banks in this
downturn they actually have they don't
seem to have done well first of all
these not as many of these big banks
many of the big banks that got into
trouble I had investment banking
operations which is really what did them
in but as far as I know about the
default rates I don't think they want is
wild us as the countrywide's and the
other big big subprime lenders did they
tend to be pretty sober folks brother
call here Danbury Connecticut next
independent caller all right good
morning thanks for taking my call one
brief observation and two quick
questions um you know what caller a
couple of minutes ago said well the bank
holds the note so there's not much I can
do about that well mr. Wagoner I believe
your name is what do you make of this
these reports report that in some cases
the bank can't even produce the note and
that these notes some of these notes
have been sliced and diced and
derivatives there's that observation if
you had any information on that and two
of the quick points either call back in
two thousand five or two thousand six
bankruptcy law was changed in this
country in many ways pushed through by
the credit card companies where people
even if they were facing bankruptcy due
to terrible health bills um could not
seek protection in it in a court where
the judge could clam down the balance
due on credit card
that kind of thing isn't it time we
revisit that and finally what do you
think we'll see in this announcement on
Wednesday or Thursday about mortgage
rates coming down or not rates but
making payments fit within thirty one to
thirty eight percent of someone's income
that's what i'm hearing the announcement
may be from the Obama administration
I'll take my answer off the air thanks
so much hey those are all great
questions I thank you much yeah you're
quite right a lot of these notes have
been been sold off to other people and
in fact that was one of the problems
because the the mortgage broker would
collect a fee on the on selling the note
the bank would would make the loan
collect a fee for making it alone they'd
sell it off to Wall Street Wall Street
would slice and dice at 12 ways and
ultimately you know your your bits and
pieces of your mortgage would wind up in
you know villages in Norway and things
like that that is a problem and that's
something that you know is this very
thorny not to work out because normally
if the bank just held the note in its
own portfolio you go up to them and say
you know and work things out face to
face now there's this whole extra layer
of legalities on top of it because the
people who own these securities backed
by the mortgages also have rights and so
it becomes a much thorny er legal
problem you're quite right about the
bankruptcy reform bill that was passed a
while ago it makes it more onerous and
more difficult to to declare bankruptcy
I would imagine that at some point that
this will come back up for examination
and finally you know setting the income
limits always seemed like kind of a good
idea to me if it's what banks used to do
and what banks many good banks still do
is that you have to have some you know
reasonable limit on on how much you can
lend to somebody based on their ability
to repay which I always understood was
the business of banking some have called
for the government to mandate an
interest rate can government do that
what is the downside of doing it well
the government used to mandate the
interest rates on savings accounts for
example you can only pay five percent I
don't know
I remember the days when they used to
save maximum interest allowable by law
which was five person on banks they may
be able to it depends on how broad on a
federally chartered bank I would imagine
they would have more pull than they
would with say a you know an independent
lender and certainly now that banks are
taking these huge amounts of money from
the government people could argue that
the bank is saying you know hey we're in
it together now we're shareholders and
it's our job to protect taxpayers and
make sure that you don't do anything
silly with this money business writer
John Wagner from USA Today with us until
ten o'clock Eastern we're taking your
calls your questions in particular about
your own financial situation personal
finance question Chantilly Virginia next
caller and on our Republican line hi
yeah good morning thanks for c-span
morning mr. Wagner hi yeah what would
all due respect on the the tax credit
coming back to folks 400 if you're
single 800 if you're married everybody
the press everybody needs to start
decoupling what folks got last year
which was a nice check that could go out
and spend this 13 of 14 dollar a week up
checkin in people's paychecks is going
to do 0 so whatever thought went into
giving people thirteen dollars a week is
a waste of money there's so many other
options available to stimulate not only
the economy but people's desire to
continue to pay their mortgage and we're
just not going there mandating to banks
that they reset loans to a thirty five
thirty eight percent income to debt
ratio is just one it makes perfect sense
people stay in their homes the banks get
their money and whatever they are are
debited that's where the tarp comes in
that's where the federal government
comes in to make the balance sheets work
to the banks advantage but everybody
wins there and I don't see any movement
along those lines to actually help what
the root cause of this problem is which
is these foreclosures
Thank You Virginia thank you um well you
know I think any spending bill and any
bill this size involves a lot of
compromises and a good compromise leaves
no one happy I think the idea behind
using the tax credit as you know kind of
a as a payroll device was really more as
a way that people would not just take
the money and pay off the credit card
bill so much as they would you know
spend it on a weekly basis but that's
the law and clearly some people are not
happy with it as far as you know making
banks you know go back to that level of
income I think that's all you know it's
an interesting idea and be interesting
to see what Congress does with it
Chicago's next Democratic caller morning
I gotta hey morning I got a couple of
questions and one observation yeah
hopefully the next stimulus bill and
don't have to be another one because
this one just won't be a panacea won't
fall a lot of the eels will have to do
something with the student loans or
perhaps a suspension a payment of some
sort second thing is they're people who
do have retirement accounts but they
can't get access to it hopefully the
next and whistle of interject some ID
laughter how those who have all those
tough retirement counts be able to
access them that money you mean this is
Chicago you mean access it without
getting taxed is that we're talking
about well sometimes there's a for
example if you're a teacher's union
unless you leave the position for four
months then you can't gain access to a
retirement account so you have to
essentially a leave your job hopefully
we'll be able to unknot some of that and
allow access at least a small access so
you can use when I wanted to pay down
certain debts or even you know Faye to
purchase things to stimulate the economy
also want to talk a little bit briefly
about the foreclosure issues in the
housing industry the I think America was
able to see a first hand what African
eric has been going through a lot when
it comes to the housing industry looking
African American communities for years
they would make an investment but to a
service and it was almost a
disinvestment because when they try to
fill their home they couldn't and their
property values of course would not win
rise the level of the counterparts
because their african-american
communities but what would have happened
in America to a large extent everyone
was able to see how the how the industry
affects the entire nation but also an
ideal of how it affected African
Americans thank you chicago sure a
couple things the the stimulus bill does
have a provision for student loans that
it makes it gives a larger tax credit
twenty five hundred dollars versus
eighteen hundred dollars a year and it
goes for all four years instead of two
years and it also allows you to use a
course materials which means books in
most cases as as part of the things that
you can claim for that credit so there
is there is some help their retirement
accounts is another thing that people
can debate about it it's very onerous
now to to get into your retirement
account in some cases cases you can't
and you can argue that that's for good
reason you shouldn't be dipping into
your retirement accounts you know for
daily expenses or anything like that but
for many people that's now their biggest
single asset and they need to you know
they may need to tap it in emergencies
and so that's another thing that you
might want to write your Congressman
about is the ability to to tap that as
far as foreclosures go it does strike
home just what enormous engine of growth
the housing industry has been and you
think about it not only when you buy a
house do you buy you know you know you
buy things to furnish it but you employ
a workmen and you know every time a lot
goes into a house that stimulates the
economy so all these things are
important and so that's why they're very
concerned with getting the housing
industry back up and running um were
months away from two months away from
tax time from tax deadline is there
anything that will change in this year
the 2008 tax year based on the stimulus
is there any change that people should
be aware of something that should keep
in mind that's what is passed in this
bill but will be will affect the current
current your taxes 2008 no there's
really not much that's going to going to
help you from further 2008 taxes if
you're you know right now the biggest
thing you can do to reduce your taxes if
you have if it's available to you a you
know traditional IRA you could do but
pretty much that year is gone and this
year is beckoning on you new world that
caller asked about accessing his
retirement accounts is it is it
counterproductive or harmful to does it
discourage savings by the government
taxing interest on up beyond a certain
level unlike money markings market funds
and savings accounts well to an extent
it does a man particularly when you're
talking with rates at this level
interest is tax bill at your normal you
know income tax rate the last time I
looked the average money fund is
yielding half a percent you might be
able to get two percent maybe three
percent in a bank CD so if you're giving
away you know a third of that to taxes
you certainly not keeping up with
inflation and there's no you know you're
not getting any benefit except that
you're not losing money next call for
our for John Wagner Dayton Ohio good
morning a Republican hi good morning and
these fans good talking to you but why
I'm talk to you for about a month now
but well that's perfect then come what's
your question ok I understand euless
package the they never did get a chance
to read everything that's in this thing
as pages and pages pages of it and
they're rushing this thing through here
I don't know it's been a two or three
weeks ago only people who called in have
an idea and to stimulate the economy and
I think his idea
was it in your giving trillions of
dollars to these programs Annette give
each individual $250,000 this one this
would get back into the economy real
quickly you know I'd back that that
would be a wonderful thing but you know
a and actually ends here so that's kind
of the heart of the problem which is our
heart of debate really is if you're
going to stimulate the economy what is
the best way to do it do you give each
person to check as the previous
administration did or do you you know
try to put it as an investment as it
were into building roads and bridges and
things that will create jobs right now
what's interesting is that you know we
had so many layoffs in the last month
and a half that I think the
administration feels that it's time to
at least stop that particular bleeding
and try to stop the you know that this
vertical climb in the unemployment rate
and try to stabilize the economy so that
by creating jobs and and and that's what
they're arguing now another half hour of
your calls with John Wagoner up to ten
o'clock eastern and also your emails as
well you can email us a journal at C
span org a viewer writes from ingleside
IL Illinois my wife's 401k has lost
about twenty percent of its worth in the
past year her losses would have been
greater but in 2004 she moved the bulk
of the funds into low risk and lower
turn funds she's 65 and intends on
working for at least two more years
rather than the retirement funds
continue to lose their value has it been
considered to allow people to cash out
or withdraw the remaining money from
their 401 accounts without tax penalty I
haven't heard that being floated and of
course if you have a 401k you could put
more into your you know your safe
options what people should remember
though is the UK say okay so you're
going to retire in two years that
doesn't mean in two years you can take
out all your money and spend it okay
you're going to theoretically spend that
over the next 30 years so that if you
have to take what start taking money
the next two years what you do is you
start to take money out of what is held
up the best I either the safe things and
give your investments that have had
losses little time to recover and so
that's that's one way to his health he
mentioned twenty percent what's been the
average what was the average loss in for
one market for three market twenty
percent or more twenty percent would be
standard but you know people who were
more aggressive who were in the stock
market stock markets down forty-four
percent in the past well since the top
in 2007 so it's it's been grim and in
fact you know people have lost over the
last decade about thirteen percent in
stocks which is awful it's the worst
record really since the 1970s we've had
two major bear markets we've had also
collapses in international stocks which
people thought would have some benefit
so it's been tough and your newspaper
has a story in the the money section
today a headline is bad sign CEOs aren't
buying stock in their companies why is
that a bad sign well because normally
you know they tend to be pretty savvy
buyers which is that they tend to buy
this talk when they think it's pretty
cheap and people do tend to look at it
it's called insider buying but it's not
the illegal type it's the legal type
that right they declare it so that if
you see a lot of CEO is buying stock and
this means actually like pulling money
out of their own pocket and buy a shock
sort of they're not just this cute thing
sure they just get right handed a bunch
of stock and say thing thank you very
much we're they actually making out
right by that's generally considered a
very positive sign for a stock so if
they're not buying you know they're
probably saying
not yet Omaha Nebraska next independent
line hi there hi there you're on the air
go ahead oh thank you enjoy your show
very much I always listen to the bankers
here in you stay with the Senators and
about the foreclosure situation and I
think it's because the people don't have
jobs and if they do find a job just like
minimum wage or you know real low wages
because a lot of these jobs aren't
unionized and if you had better paying
jobs people could for to stay in their
homes and make their mortgage payments
so that's why I just I think there's so
much foreclosures going on people took
out loans they couldn't afford and then
they lose their job and on the mr.
jealous was on I have a comment about
that if a President Lincoln when he
frees the phrase he would have sent all
those people back to their own country
they won't be having all these problems
here you know in united states that are
still having today nebraska will let you
go there and if mr. wagoner you want to
comment on the on the foreclosure
comment that she made yeah the the
problem the way before closures is a big
problem and one of the things that
aggravates it of course is losses of
jobs when you know when people lose
their jobs becomes even someone who has
a sensible mortgage it becomes very hard
for them to to pay their mortgage one of
the lessons that we learned in the
depression and may have forgotten was
that hard times can come to anybody and
the thing that I guess we should think
about too is that from 2003-2006
corporations are in record profits some
three trillion dollars in profits of
which you know working people saw very
little of there was very little growth
in wages during that period so yeah
everybody could use a raise or we could
like to keep the job and I really like
to avoid foreclosure the money section
of USA Today just just full good news
this morning retailers troubles ripple
across the USA they talk about this year
alone the possibility of 150,000 retail
outlets closing across the country in a
picture here of a fellow standing
outside of circuit city which announced
it was going out of business is it too
early to tell but what is your thought
on what the the future of retail America
looks like well you know it is
disturbing because in the last couple
weeks if you walk through them all or
you go through outlet centers or even
particularly if you go through smaller
towns and you know look at the little
shops that appeared in the last three
four years and they're just closing down
at an awful rate and that's disturbing
because clearly you know the small
businesses are one of the big are the
biggest employer in the United States
and when people have two people don't
shutter their business lightly I mean
it's a wrenching decision nobody wants
to give up their business and to me
that's you know along with these massive
layoffs that are announced in the
newspaper it's these small shops
shutting literatures just heartbreaking
and also very disturbing as far as
retailing I think as long as they're you
know America's an entrepreneurial
country and but what you really need is
someone to say you know I think the
economy is picking up a little bit I
think I could make some money you know
selling X selling wine offering this
service and you know right now I don't I
don't hear anybody saying that Kansas
City excuse me Garden City Kansas next
caller Republican good morning
Democratic line I'm sorry go ahead good
morning it thank you for taking my call
I guess I have some a comment and a
question my wife and I are in our early
sixties we have our home paid for we
have no credit card debt we have always
lived very very conservative like I'm
not saying this to be funny that I think
the most we've ever paid for a higher
than forty five hundred dollars we have
money in the bank and Vienna we we have
no plans on on a were retiring our goal
is to continue to continue to work as
long as we possibly can what bothers me
is that we have lived very
conservatively we have played by the
rules 15 we hear about these I hear
about these bailouts etc and I'm
wondering why you know why did I pay my
bills why did i do the things that I was
supposed to do when I saw people buy
cars that they couldn't afford and give
them back buy homes that they couldn't
afford and here we hear that I hear that
you're being helped out this this really
bothers me thank you Kansas well as my
mom used to say virtue is its own reward
many people around you are suffering and
you're in good shape and and that's a
good thing in fact one could argue that
if you have money in the bank this is
the best time to have money because
other people don't if you were to buy
something you know interested in buying
something as an investment just about
everything on the planet is for sale
right now you get the mid at bargain
prices but I do hear that from people
who say you know hey I paid my mortgage
I've done the right thing
where's my check well another viewer
writes in on that along that line my
question for mr. Wagner is what is the
outlook for savers in the sochi in a
socio-economic environment that is being
created by both the banking crisis in
the stimulus package which columns
consumption does seem to me that it does
seem that the that the bernanke fed is
indifferent to the value of cash and
savings income which is a source of
spending for many responsible people you
talked about the saving grace a few
minutes ago as in pretty doggone low
yeah they are pretty low and I was
thinking about that the other day
interest oh sure yeah and and and in
fact it as a real rate of return which
it's negative you know in that at least
theoretically last 12 months inflation
has been higher than any rate you would
have gotten right of a bank particularly
after after taxes so it's a tough time
for Sabre now on the other hand I you
know from nineteen forty through the
early 70s rates were very low also and
people just socked away money in the
bank because that's what you did and it
was nice if you got some interest but it
wasn't like you're going to get rich on
it I think what people forget is that in
your at the end of your time period when
you're saving the vast bulk of what
you'll have under almost any condition
is the amount you put away okay it's not
the amount you earn you'll always have
about two-thirds of your principal is
going if your balance is going to be
what you put away another third is going
to be what you earned so except for the
rare cases where you you know pick a
stock and you knock it out of the park
most times your own savings is is your
best source of retirement income so you
have to bear in mind that some day rates
will be higher and you know we'll get
through this but your your biggest
engine of retirement growth is is is
yourself next caller tamarac florida
good morning yeah hi good morning mr.
Wagner I thank you for being there
I feel very much the same way as that
previous caller and I lost an awful lot
of money I had saved all my life I have
no debt either here's my question I
worried that the banks are going to
close I'm worried about the government
and what they're going to do what kind
of investments with what we have left do
you feel would be the appropriate thing
like a fixed annuity or corporate stock
I I'm not even you know sure that the
markets are not going to crash right
well the market so far I've had kind of
a slow-motion crash now we're down forty
five percent from its high which pretty
much puts us in the made major league of
bear markets in the past hundred years
or so now the worst was a great
depression that was an eighty-nine
percent decline so that's the you know
if you ever want to know what what's the
worst that could happen there you have
it the thing is is that if you're
looking for safety okay if you just say
I just don't want to lose any money I
just want to keep my principal intact
you're fine with the bank deposit within
the FDIC limits of $250,000 which you
can increase by different ways of
titling it if your bank collapses in the
FTC FDIC goes under well we have other
things to worry about writing stuff like
that I think the government is good good
on its word now people will say you know
okay but if this is all ultimately
inflationary does it mean then that you
know the government is taking my money
through inflation and that's something
people have to worry about now to the
government does have something called
tips Treasury inflation-protected
securities which are very cheap right
now the rise in value as as inflation
Rises it's it's a good bet people who
are really hardcore about inflation
fears and I don't think it's a bad idea
put a portion of their money in gold a
David Carr writing in The New York Times
today about
media is covering the economic situation
the finance financial markets the
headline is in his column today is this
just in the market is still dead
financial journalists can't figure out
how to cover this tour / is the headland
subhead so is it more interesting more
difficult to cover this current time
than say and the article is pieces about
how the particularly the cable outlets
are struggling to to cover this I'm sure
I think it's most fascinating time and
financial history i mean i think there's
four people who have money as whenever
caller said there's incredible
opportunities in many stocks certainly
in corporate bonds you know you can get
a great yield on General Electric bond
you know and who would have thought that
this is more interesting to you this
time this this period then say covering
when the markets rallying and going
through the roof well yeah it is partly
because when the markets rallying going
through the roof you know that people
are going to get caught up in the
euphoria and they'll probably invest too
much in something they shouldn't and and
you try to tell people you know gee I
don't I don't think technology stocks
are gonna you know go up fifty percent a
year for the next ten years and I could
be wrong but and they won't listen to
you but what is interesting now is this
is affects a major I think a major piece
of our history you know bull markets
people think of fondly but now I think
the government and business have some
real decisions to make about how our
financial system is run how to avoid the
things that we've done this time and how
altima tlie to plot our road back to
prosperity I mean I think the thing that
people forget is that you know sooner or
later these things do pass and you know
the Sun comes out again but the problem
is is you have you know you have
journalists who are in a depressed
industry talking to people in financial
services who are in a depressed industry
so it becomes this kind of or of
negativity I think I think things will
eventually you know come back it's going
to be tough boo yeah we'll make it about
15 more minutes with John Wagoner rights
for USA Today their business reporter
and investment columnist and also the
author of bail
up it's right what what the collapse of
bear stearns means for you right thing
again is the investor and a look at it
online there as we go to Louisville
Kentucky independent caller good morning
Louisville yeah I just wanted to say a
couple of things and just ask you a
question one is I think I know a lot of
people who have borrowed or you know
like people that I work with that are
300,000 dollars in credit card debt
literally and they use it to buy lunches
and things like that and I always tell
people that if you're using a credit
card to buy lunch means basically you're
borrowing money from a company to buy
lunch if you're doing that something's
wrong there you shouldn't be doing that
now another thing is is that when i look
at the housing market and I see it and I
say okay you know part of the problem
that I see is the reason that there are
so many foreclosures because you had so
many people over the last you know let's
say ten years maybe eight years whatever
that you can't necessarily afford to
make their payments and I think a part
of that goes is because you know you had
like Fair Housing Act and you know even
n double acp like the guy they were just
talking to a little while ago and
they're trying to force these companies
to loan to minorities but maybe that
minorities can't afford it but they're
forcing them to have a certain amount of
percentage of loaning to them and and so
to me when I look at the company's
they're trying to be you know they're
trying to stay good or whatever in the
media sighs and they want to look good
to all these people so they will almost
force themselves to loan to maybe
minorities when they come in even though
they kind of know that they can't afford
it my question is is is there is there
going to be any time in the foreseeable
future that they're going to maybe
loosen up and maybe even just say you
know what let's not do racial tracking
let's just track what people can afford
you know what I'm saying like if they
can afford to buy it it's all fair it
doesn't matter what color you are
either can't afford to buy it or you
can't thanks caller well the Community
Reinvestment Act was designed actually
to do just that to make sure that thanks
who were taking deposits within a
community meant fairly to those people
in the community and it was designed to
help a despicable practice called
redlining which is when you would simply
you know Wolof whole sections of
minority communities and say well we're
not going to lend to them because
they're minorities and in fact much of
the problems in the housing market came
from really the high end you know these
guys were buying million-dollar houses
with no documentation and they were
called yellow Doc no doc loans so called
liar's loans and these kinds of
shenanigans were what really brought a
lot of banks down it was you know
florida retirement homes it was guys
were flipping houses for you know fun
and profit so it's disingenuous to say
that the you know the Community
Reinvestment Act brought our what was
upon us it really had very little to do
with it Valdosta Georgia good morning on
our demo on our Republican line
Republican life oh yes good morning
gentlemen I think that last guy was kind
of a goof on that I keep hearing that
same thing over and over again about
people wouldn't spent more than they had
went and spent more than they had this
person housings and goes in that with
all those people are therefore and that
was the mortgage brokers there the loan
originator the appraiser and all these
other people who are supposed to be
experts in the field they're supposed to
be looking at this in deciding whether
the loan is worthy or not you know they
somehow they all got off the hook and
all made money because they were all
getting paid per deal that's really what
drove it was greed but here to me the
biggest problem is is wages way too many
people have been making way too little
money for way too long they just don't
have anymore you know yeah there's
people who go out waste money I'm sure
yeah I've seen them but that's not
that's not the majority of the problem
the majority of the problem is is wages
for most people just haven't haven't
kept up there there were they work 20 or
30 years ago that's how low they are in
there all right Georgia well those are
both you know extremely good points i
think you know first of all as far as
the mortgage mess goes there's plenty of
blame to go around you can blame people
for taking out mortgages that they
shouldn't have done but on the other
hand as you point out banks are in the
business of lending money and you know
for them to say gee you know i don't
think any banks are saying it's not my
fault but it's their fault too and it's
their money and now our money that they
lent out and lost and they bear a great
deal of responsibility for that now as
far as wages you are absolutely correct
because not only on in real terms have
wage has been fairly stagnant but if you
think about it every year you're asked
to pay a little more for your health
insurance you realize you have to spend
a little you have to save a little more
for your retirement and in fact that
cuts down on the amount of money that
you really have to spend now there was a
time when when you know people did have
fairly low cost health insurance with a
good employer and they did have a
pension with a good employer this was
not universal but it certainly happened
and for people who had that they've seen
a real decline in their in their real
spending power over the last 10-15 years
and you're absolutely right thee the
wages have not kept up with people's
ability to you know to live the life
they would like to on the lighter side
of financial collapses the New York
Daily News the toy shows in New York
this week and reporting on a toy maker
in New York has the smash me up Bernie
Dahl of Bernie Madoff a picture here of
the toy maker and his hammy pamer at the
ready of mr. Madoff on the serious side
though that that the fallout of that
investment is affecting especial a lot
of people very very wealthy people what
is likely to be the regulatory outcome
of that collapse what's likely to be the
upside of this this this madoff scandal
whenever you have these kinds of
enormous frauds which are always come
their part and parcel of manias you know
when you have a stock mania or a housing
mania you have frauds because that's
that's where the money is as John
Dillinger said so what you will likely
see is not just more regulation which
your by and large the securities
industry is fairly tightly regulated but
what you need are more inspectors you
know you need more people who are
trained to go out and detect fraud the
is an SDC function that's an SEC
function and you know those guys work
really hard they're really smart but
there's not a lot of them and they're
also up against you know if you're an
SEC lawyer you have a lot of power at
your hands but you're also up against
you know the the best and brightest
lawyers on Wall Street and they can
delay you and and play pretty tough
hardball too so you know you whenever
you have big amounts of money kicking
around in the you know in the system you
need somebody to watch it and they need
somebody you know who you can pay
decently and who feels like there's a
future and their job and feel strongly
about it because you these amounts of
money are not best left to somebody else
about 10 more minutes with John Wagoner
and your personal financial questions
Geiger town Pennsylvania next call on
our Democrat hi morning hi this is Diane
and I have another comment I was being
trained in the mortgage industry so I
know what was going on and they were
doing exactly it's not the people's
fault they were creatively like say if
the woman had good credit they would
make her income and Amanda they would
forget him and alone and just add his
income to her if her title could go
along with it and they knew ahead of
time because this was before this all
happened and they gave me an old book
that was a year before and I said all
about these all days and no doc loans
and I went in one day about six months
to eight months before all this happened
they suddenly said we're changing how we
do everything
and they suddenly stop some of that kind
of loan so they knew the mortgage it was
greed I say it's all just been greed
exactly like George I really agreed with
him and it's the people on the bottom
have been doing the work like you yeah I
think it's you have said and the people
have top have been taking all the money
and now no longer if you draw a pyramid
we have the workers at the bottom no
longer can we support the people up at
the top by making so little anymore it
has to be either shared I'm in school so
I can make more but again and I'm not
young I'm back in school so I can make
more but I really agree you're the first
person that really hits about all the
points and I thank you for that and I
really agree with Georgia and Kentucky
is really really that guy from Kentucky
sounds a little projective prejudiced
because it's not two people let's look
it's the million-dollar houses that I
said that when i sold my sister of
course they can afford their house but i
saw all these houses that were a real
high price in their area and I thought
well where are these people going to
work eventually there's is that many
good paying jobs alright Pennsylvania
well you're right you know I think yeah
there was this brief moment we all said
gei suddenly I live in a you know a
half-million-dollar house or something
like that and of course you have to
think you know your neighbors and a
half-million-dollar house and for half a
million dollars you know should you
really have two bathrooms in a basement
and so you can tell when these things
get out of hand but part of the the base
problem is income you know you can't
have this huge rise in house prices if
people are not enjoying a similar rising
income I want to ask you about college
financing and what's your best guidance
you'd give to a parent of high school
senior or generally a freshman as the
process starts how has the economy
changed the planning phase that word
where do they begin well so for someone
in college for somebody with a with a
child in high school stuff okay well the
first is you know thinking of the
cardinal rule
finances save as much as you can look
for you look for whatever scholarships
you can get also state schools I think
are great things I think you should
really think twice if the benefit of
paying 40 thousand dollars a year for a
college a particular college is worth it
particularly in the first two years you
know english comp is english comp i
don't think it really matters whether
you take it at harvard or you take a
local community college i mean i think
it's just a wave of the basic courses
that that you're going to get anywhere
so you can save money by you know taking
some of your basic courses you know at a
place that's not going to charge you an
arm and a leg but this is another thing
if you think about the things that a
young couple has to save for when
they're starting out of their 25 so
you're thinking you want to have a
million dollars or so saved up for
retirement you think you're going to
have 120 thousand dollars for college
you're thinking you're going to need
250,000 for our house or let's let's
give them between you give them down
payments let's say 25 thought the ten
percent down payment 35,000 I don't know
many 25 year olds who can put away that
much money I mean they'll be they'll be
you know camping out in the park maybe
but I think it's very high goal and
without you no family support and
support of others I think it's very
difficult for people next call is from
Auburn Kentucky good morning Republican
caller Kentucky you're sorry your new
york i'm sorry go ahead all right yes
valve I much great program gentlemen got
a question a couple a two-part question
one is I guess I need a little bit more
clarification on the individual text
emulous you would mention i thought at
the beginning of the program that if you
owed four hundred dollars at the end of
the year you might get a tax credit of
four hundred dollars and then maybe not
owing anything but then we talked about
uh this
payroll increases say seven to thirteen
dollars for patriot we're going to be
able to have an option here or did I
miss something and the second part is
Trey a family burning forty five
thousand dollars a year with six
exemption how is this stimulus going to
affect what they may get back in return
at the end of the year right oh 440 are
you going caller yeah 45,000 is your
your your adjusted gross income or what
so we okay yeah basically for most
people they'll get it through
withholding okay if it happens to be
that you don't use that up in
withholding then you would get you know
the remaining amount in a tax credit
that would be you know a bit more
unusual and be a fairly low income thing
so for the vast amount of people that's
going to be taken out out through
withholding now as so for the person
with forty five thousand dollars in
Jessica gross income I think that's
going to be the main extent of your
basic tax benefit now their tax benefits
for other things buy a house by a car
have a kid going to school all these
things will work to you know reduce your
your income your taxes further but your
basic benefit is going to be through
withholding let's say aloha to hawaii
kauai hawaii la scala this morning hi
there yeah hi thank you a funny got
through yeah so let me tell you I'm an
immigrant and I'm Americans to this from
now what I can never understand the
American politics simply like to have it
Republican you have a Democrat
independent you know that's all kind of
dumb because is a human problem has
nothing to do with politics is insane is
the way separating lines but go ahead
with your comments about that that
doesn't address the issue and all what
we're talking about it now in ninety
percent of all everybody had talked
about it
is on what under the bridge is all kind
of done nothing B&W don't address the
real problem how we going to punish
those those criminals who got into that
problem the independent guy if they
don't know how to a take care of the
household is too bad then go under you
know but same thing like we religion
this country I like to see the do ban
all major organized religion and then
all of the nice politics I think we
would be much better off and get some of
those the old ways when they had the
tribal leaders when they want charge who
flinches someone to get something wrong
or need some help well thank you so much
Indian dancers for that you know the
Romans banned all political parties
after a civil war they felt it was a bad
bad thing but it's just the way we do
things we have a ways to argue things
out and we have people who gravitate
towards Republican solutions and
democratic solutions i agree that at
some point you have to stop saying well
who's responsible for this and who's
responsible that and try to like fix the
problem there's plenty of time for
congressional hearings in court cases
and things like that you know later on
down the road but really what I think
this economy is its administration and
the last have said we have to do
something now we have to take action we
have to stop the economy from bleeding
out and employment and we have to deal
with that first and then once that's
settled try to you know there's there's
there's plenty of time to blame people
are still people who walk out of the
room and Roosevelt's name is mentioned
so you know it's a this time for that
but right now we have to fix things what
money store you writing on next for yes
I today I'm working on a story about
gold and fears of inflation and gold
prices have been up quite a bit been up
quite a bit lately and gold sales are
going to the roof and there's a lot of
people who are very keenly interested in
gold because it's that ancient store
value that people trust and we'll see
that story this week yes John Wagoner
rights for USA Today read his work on
line at the usatoday.com thanks for
taking all the questions we appreciate
it thanks so much